i have a minute and a half left um
i just see to put it on the prompt to
hear ruth bader ginsburg just died
no way good job the way you checked the
prompter like i'm lying
no i'm shocked i know but i told you you
can believe me
yeah remember when i was mr optimism at
the beginning of the panel
it's this is going to get really really
ugly
right really really ugly because
mcconnell is going to just jam that
through
right there's just he has no uh this is
the one thing he's got no compunction
about
no so this whole like oh last time it
was an election year
wait it out and this is so much no way
that mcconnell's and this is so much
closer
to the election i think scalia died in
february right
this is right before an election this is
like literally the worst case scenario
endlessly and who is going to be the
next supreme court judge rodney look
yeah look at
scott baio yeah yeah frat yeah amy co
amy barrett i think some
seems like a laura ingram if you're a
judge i think is going to be the
person amy coney barrett that's yeah
that that is very
very sad news yeah that's horrible
horrible first of all before we go on to
the
political part of it she was just
awesome yeah
and yeah i mean
and and you know i've said it before on
this show power begets power this is why
you cannot let a guy like
trump become president because it's not
just about the president
right right
yeah there's super liberals who don't
want to vote for biden because like he's
not liberal enough
i just can't i can't do i can't handle
that [ __ ] any time you know
because of this like this is why you
have to just swallow that
seventy thousand votes well we have a
show we're gonna move on
we're gonna get over it hopefully we're
gonna be okay but let me bring
jane into the picture here she is the
academy award-winning actress and
founder of fire drill fridays
his new book is called what can i do my
path from climate despair to action
please welcome jane fonda
i'm still reeling bill i'm just i just
heard
that ruth bader ginsburg died and
we have to be as tough as mitch
mcconnell and not allow them to do
one frigging thing until the election
is over i mean we have to rise up and
not allow them to do it if mitch
mcconnell can do it let's get
some grow some balls and ovaries and
use it oh my god
you